the council had an exchange of views on
the omnibus regulation which proposes
updates legislation in several areas
including the Common Agricultural Policy
the council also decided to mobilize the
EU solidarity fund to help the United
Kingdom cyprus and also portugal
repaired the damage caused by natural
disasters today we also discussed the
simplification of the sea AP with a
focus on the period post 2020 I can find
my intervention to reminding the Council
of the purpose of the proposal which is
namely simplification and of the need to
have it implemented quickly in a way the
benefit farmers from the first of
January 2018 in view of the ambitious
timetable I did make the binder
amendments that are seeking more
far-reaching policy reform could
compromise our ability to deliver on
time and should remain to be considered
for the post-2020 reform today I had the
opportunity to debrief the ministers of
agriculture on my visit to Brazil lastly
and on the latest state of play on the
fraudulent practices the brazilian meat
sector our exchange was Fran and my
message was clear the safety of food
products exported to the EU is not
optional I stressed that it is up to
Brazil to restore trust
you